literally one of my favorite things
that's ever happened on a movie paid
that's me and his money Malkovich you
know the fact that he was even going to
come to do this movie the whole crew was
talking about it I mean for months we're
waiting for John Malkovich to get there
I mean it's a big deal when he finally
shows up he gets there and at that point
he's walking on water we do the first
take and John goes if you don't have my
money then you
fine and I'm sitting across the table
from him like I'm sorry what what what
did you just say you me
straight up we're talking like this and
suddenly the action if you know
my money and the crew burst into
Applause they're cheering they're like
wow amazing amazing and I'm looking at
him and I guess he sees me looking at
him and he leans across the table he
goes
terrible actor